it's all about business because the top
eight will perform as the show is a lie
which means that the show has to stage
eight mini concerts in a row with no
time to spare in between it's an amazing
race against the fog trust me
so we went behind the scenes to find out
how they do that
here's what you see all in one show
spectacular stage effect
flames right behind a performer
flashing lights floor-to-ceiling and
here's what you don't see the army of
stagehands are rushing to change the
scenery after each act the production
team on the voice is really crazy they
put things up and take them apart as if
it is formula 170 guys have about three
and a half minutes to switch out one
huge group of set pieces for another
with television it's a little bit
different
turnaround time is crazy it's fun at the
same time because it kind of keeps you
on your toes
team Christina's performances are
produced by Gerry slaughter with
Christina she's definitely loves to go
like all the way out there she loves the
high glam the drama I just tried to make
them shine in whatever capacity what I
feel is right for them as as artists
what you don't see in the dress
rehearsal a smoke test 14 Christina's
Allison Porter
that goes off without a hitch what you
see on the show a lot of Carson Daly
give it up the boy about to stop what
you don't see a stand-in for rehearsal
what you see on the show are spectacular
sweeping shots of the performers what
you don't see are the crew guys cameras
and cables that pull it off
speaking of fire well this set up 14
Blake's out of Wakefield looks a little
dangerous but it's not according to
staging supervisor Joe Barry it's
primarily a pipe with a bunch of cuts in
it that's buried in the rocks just like
you have in your backyards and within
minutes that flaming setup disappears
it's pretty incredible how they do it is
so impressive but it's kind of down to a
science
very impressive and here's something
that I found a really interesting a fire
is allowed on the set as you saw but
water is not and that's because water
can leak the places that it's not
supposed to and then that wouldn't be
fair to the next performer because
obviously Vegas live